sheath underwear oh yeah we got to do
these live
uh sheath underwear it is good
it is good a lot of the things we
advertise we don't even know what they
are
before we read the ads we really have no
idea
i remember when we were advertising
monday.com and they got mad i'm like i
don't know what he did i read the whole
ad i go i don't know what it is
still i didn't know what it was
monday.com i'm like i don't know what is
it
they're like it's a peer-to-peer
software i'm like what
what is this but she's underwear is
underwear it's actually
underwear it's good it's uh it's support
you have the pouch for your penis
and balls and if you're a woman with a
penis and balls
or a man with a penis in balls or you
don't identify in the gender binary and
you have a penis in balls or you've
added a
nice tiny little penis and balls it was
sculpted
out of a vagina like some flabby loose
vag skin that they made into a little
vienna sausage corkscreen but you're
like [ __ ] yeah
i feel better like this or if you've
taken a penis
and then i often think of doing this and
just splitting it right down the middle
and throwing up the turkey on either
side of the leg
and and having a vag but i still keep my
sack
any configuration of 2021 genitalia
sheath
underwear is great whether it's a [ __ ]
or just a flab of [ __ ] beef you want
to stick in there
you can do whatever you need you could
swim in them we use them as swimsuits
you know they're great
doesn't matter it's good you should uh
the guy's a big comedy fan which is why
i can do this
if you go to sheath underwear.com is
this the guy who's in the military
uh yes yes yes yes yes
this guy started an underwear company uh
after he got back from iraq
so support him uh sheath underwear dot
com use code tim
to save 20 off if you use code tim
you save 20 off the underwear uh
then this is better help
i mean if you've listened to the show if
you have any
familiarity with this show
the idea that this company
i mean truly amazing
that they would do this ad we promised
to be good for this run of the
and i'm being good you're being good i'm
saying
i'm shocked yeah and pleasantly
surprised
we have a long history we have a long
history
with them and that's nice
but it's good because what it is is it's
counseling do you get that it's
counseling when you sad or when you're
mad
dan has problem you went to a therapist
right dan has probably cause
plenty problems dan graduated college
and went wait a minute why
why do i have to leave it you know many
shitty people in his generation are like
why do the beer pong tournaments have to
end but they do so he got sad about that
he was sad and he had to go to a
therapist and go i don't understand
what's going on he had to leave florida
he'd leave the beach put on shoes and be
a human being
and it was sad and challenging and new
but during the pandemic it's
hard i'm not who cares no i just don't i
get it
i mean i love they send the copy like i
don't know what i'm doing it's
when you're sad or mad or anxious or
you're in a loveless marriage
you can call betterhelp.com atlp
betterhelp.com what's the promo code so
this i have to read directly
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and tim dillon show listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
tim d
yay all right round one of ads done
better help